charles built a rectangular table that
has a perimeter
of 20 feet and an area of 24 square feet
the table is longer than it is wide what
are the length and width of the table
the length and width are whole numbers
so it's longer than it is wide so let's
draw this table here
so the table might look something like
this
might look something like this where
this dimension this dimension right over
here is the length
so this distance right over here is the
length
we could also write length here if we
want to show that this is the same
these two sides have the same length and
then we could call this dimension right
over here this is the width
this is the width and this is
also of course the width as well this is
a rectangle
so these two sides are going to be the
same now they tell us
that the perimeter is 20 feet which is
another way of saying
that the width plus the width
plus the length plus the length
plus the length is equal to
20 is equal to 20 and they tell us that
the area is 24 square feet that's
another
way of saying that the width times the
length is going to be 24
so we could write that down with
width times the length
times the length is going to be equal to
24. now there's a lot of ways to solve
this problem
and later on when you learn more algebra
there's fancy algebraic ways to do that
but we won't have to resort to this they
tell us that the length and width are
whole numbers
so we really should just be able to try
out some numbers because we know that
the width times the length
is 24. so we just have to try all the
whole numbers that when i were to take
their product i get to 24. essentially
the product
the factors of 24 and then figure out
which of those satisfied the perimeter
up here where if i take the width plus
the width essentially
2 times the width plus 2 times the
length i am going
to get to 20. so let's figure that out
so let's make let me make two columns
here so one column
i'm going to call it a width column
another column i'm going to call it
length and then i'm going to
write down the perimeter i'll write
perimeter
i'll just shorten it with per maybe
perry
i'll just write out the whole word
perimeter and then let's write out
area let's write out
area actually let's do all that i could
write it just like that
let me try out make it a table here
so i have a table here and then i can
try things out
and what we can do is just make sure
that everything we try out has an
area of 24 square feet so
let's just think about the factors of 24
well
it could be 1 and 24 so this literally
could be
1 a width of 1 and a length of 24
1 times 24 is 24
and they tell us that the length that
the length is longer
the length is longer than the width that
the table is longer than it is wide so
we want the larger number under length
so let's see 1 times 24 is 24 but what
is
1 plus 1 plus 24 plus 24 well that's
going to be 2
plus 48 which is 50. so this doesn't
meet our condition that the perimeter is
20.
so let's cross that out so this one
right over here
this one right over here does not work
out let's try the other factors of 24.
it could be
2 and 12 once again 2 times 12
is 24. but what's 2 plus 2 it's 4
plus 12 plus 12. so it's 4 plus 24
that's going to be 28. well that doesn't
meet our perimeter
constraint so we can that's not going to
be right
well what about let's see 3 times
8 is also equal to 24
and what's 3 plus 3 is 6 plus 8 plus 8
is 16
6 plus 16 is 22. well we're getting
close but it's still not
a perimeter of 20. so that's not going
to be right
now what about what about 4 and
6. once again 4 times 6 is
24 and what's 4 plus 4 plus 6 plus 6
well that's 8 plus 12 which is
indeed equal to 20. so that works out
our width is going to be 4 feet
and our length is going to be 6 feet